une production du studio sf
mais m dos sans fil de représenter par
chris miller podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous écouter battus par
quentin avec moins d'hommes planches
talus caisse me vient de lancer deux
nouveaux produits dont les caisses de
rpost donc si vous avez des airs potes
vous avez votre caisse bhl al kib un
moyen vous pouvez avoir un nouveau
caisse originale qui ce mec des déserts
complètement une scène et ont lancé
aussi des hordes cher pour vos
ordinateurs portables donc si vous
voulez protéger vos portables moche et
que je cherche trop souvent mon laptop
concept brisé donc moi je m'en procurer
un allez voir sur leur site web c'est le
utiliser le sf ken hitchcock formule 1
reprendra bien sûr les produits semi
cette semaine donne cette semaine grand
plaisir de recevoir jean philippe
wauthier pour son premier podcast du
moins en tant qu'invité d'honneur à
contents de la voir ce que longtemps
qu'on essaye de la voie puis finalement
c'est passé en partage pour chose avec
jean-philippe une des choses principal
c'est notre passion pour l'entraînement
j'applique est un grand coureur comme
php on ne put on ne put bonne des
sources celle qui a peut aussi réfléchir
sur qu'est-ce qui poussent l'humain à
vouloir courir vouloir se dépasser à
vouloir
atteindre des objectifs est souvent
intéressant on a parlé aussi de sa
relation petits réseaux sociaux de
parler des services écrit la quarantaine
c'est vraiment super super intéressant
mais connaissent pas content d'avoir
reçu yes sans plus attendre on va aller
remercier nos sponsors à peu avant de
vous laisser à la conversation dont
celle que vous savez que ici au studio
sfr on a un espace de création podcast
est propre à la
discussion qui suscitent les
conversations pertinentes et bien sachez
qu'on loue le studio sf ça vient avec la
technique les caméras toute l'équipe va
bien même avec nicole les gens ont
besoin de faire quoi vous pouvez faire
ce que vous voulez kaluza partir durant
la durée de voir qu'il passe muraille
est attaché à une ventilation etc
semblent pas de deux
qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent pour la
question besoin de faire les légendes
tôt rien n'a fait plus beau que le
studio tu nous écrit sur les avantages
ardeurs tu viens puis on va t'aider la
création de ton podcast sata soir
discuter avec les invités ou créer le
contenu que tu veux créer vidéo audio et
on va t'aider là-dedans taxe est
clairement scc vous avez l'esprit
tranquille pour créer le meilleur
contenu que vous voulez créer au podcast
où que ce soit n'importe quoi vous
pouvez aller sur le studio est certes
moins ça pour avoir plus d'informations
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yes merci d'être là bas et mon dieu
merci l'invitation c'est pas vrai c'est
tellement rare que je fais du podcast
est mort moi mais heureux puisque j'en
enregistrés mais comme souvent été
enclenchée de la tv le mélange m'étais
dit ok lost automne
on est content et très fier
service en option des prochaines
semaines le nom mais je peux non
pourrais je posais faire maryland
joindront bientôt
ça va toujours venir ici reste sur un
classique un réajustement de série voilà
c'est vrai bon gars venaient cogner sa
raquette par qui ouais c'est 50 qui
quand même et d'un coin de ségou fenty
a rigolé avec la construction montréal y
a des potes il n'y a pas de facile
t'es pas un gars qui utilisent les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup
sur instagram qui suit ouais puis je
cache t cry tue-le tue-le voit comme pau
ou tulipes au chuv une fois tu comme dit
hagen parfait on s'organise est long
mais pauvre est juste titre m avec
l'espoir que très mauvais jeu
j'aime pas ce tant que ça dans le sens
où
j'ai deux enfants je vais m'entraîner je
travaille en randonnée titre c'est comme
tu te rends compte puis pour vrai je me
rends compte que des fois tu te
réveilles tout et réseaux sociaux plutôt
comme je commence quand on sait qu'en ce
qui me dit comme pavage je prendrais
matos plus foncés et épais je n'ai pas
entendu je l'entends la distance que je
me rends compte que je suis résolument
non ça se peut pas que je veux pas face
à hand and its et oui je sais c'est
jusque rôle un peu mais je me rends
compte qu'il ya un choix à faire soit tu
t'investis
jeune diabaté ville qui sauve est là dit
il la vieille affaire à quelque part
c'est la radio qui se trouvent encore
avec la vieille affaire et puis je pense
que ça va être super g pas cette énergie
le ppi j'ai surtout pas le cas je rate
un des messages
je partage pas ma vie sur les réseaux
sociaux cds story j'en fais rarement je
pose sur techtoc c'est pour me raconter
même dit il je suis trop tard
la date avait écrit une semaine et fait
longtemps
que
tu avais créé la page du podcast pigeons
pour t'inviter nana a répondu absolument
pas l'installation d'abris se jeter
comme au québec
public passe 4 g/j surprenamment
beaucoup de messages
secrets qu'ils trouvent je loue des fois
que je vois la liste comme
les leurs c'est le ji mail j'ai des
textos il faut que je le dis c'est
j'oublie puis le j'ai parlé je pense
départ à mon agent que des fois une
agence est vraiment utile ça se calme a
dit comme celle faut absolument qu'elle
fasse ce qui est quand même au su de
suite après que j'ai fini bonsoir les
puis on le fait dès que possible c'est
ça ça libère aussi parce que je l'aide
en tête les petits défauts et comme je
te vois pas choquant parce tiffauges
récré il faut que j'organise puis là et
tu penses au cerveau et s'éclairent play
man et comme je suis encore dans mes
messages comme accueilli who pour vrai
le sait sur tard soit trop je reçois non
mais qu'on soit tellement d'affaires
dans vie le nombre de technologies mon
téléphone le pis je sais combien de que
j'ai fait et ménages de ma boîte
courriel quand même un petit boucle puis
j'ai décidé depuis affiché le nombre de
messages de notification et puis même
plus la petite pastille rouge qui dit
quoi manger des emails parce que le
genre j'angoissais été j'ai 180 message
de les poster mais répondre y de
répondre et de répondeur pour un même
pas répondu les écouter pour écouter
un show
à las vegas 6 2 en femme
m'a
fait un choc
edouard quotidienne en direct à ce
qu'ils soient de potes restait beaucoup
de jus moteur pour grand chose au nom
c'est ça la face tout petit je remarque
pourtant non sens où si c'est un job
comme ça puis ça va puis on dirait que
tu l'as fait csu c'est un horaire que tu
dans lequel tu embarques si c'est juste
que ce sera qui durent longtemps
normalement tv ont fait ce septembre
octobre novembre début décembre sont un
mois et demi de break ont recommencé en
janvier février mars pour que ça se
finisse et le sait j'embarque fin mars
puis je finis début septembre non si tu
apprécies tu le vois pas de temps tu
t'habitues vit depuis un moment donné
quand tu finis tu te rends compte que tu
as pu moins de dépenses est bondée à
face entend rendre compte que les deux
premières semaines après que j'ai fini
mon bonsoir bonsoir je j'étais fatigué
je mens rien n'est figé pas de jus je
t'aime beaucoup donc si j'ai tu la
connais de longue il avait pour l
acheter comme je sais plus comment
analyser importante pilat ça fait deux
semaines je peignais swing ces jeux ça
vaut le
[Musique]
nom c'est sa piscine mais c'est dur de
mettre le doigt sur ce que s'est dit tom
je sais pas ce que c'est qui tu veux si
tu veux dire on top 20 des affaires du
travail ce travail comme un parfum de
mon petit mon grand père travaillait
mais puisque ce que tu dis là ça doit
pas être la fatigue accumulée mais je
pense que c'est dans taille c'est que ça
joue enfin le ca vole à ce qu'on
s'habitue au stress a l'impression
d'être en direct le temps puis de notre
entrevue au magazine oui ses paupières
mtn ses jambes je le répète la source
code ivy
et abandonner l'objectif des temps non
je pense que l'objectif de faire ce
qu'on fait ce que je pense pour moi dit
s'il est exactement ce qu on ait fait
une erreur fait une erreur quand j'étais
petit en fait danville emprunter ce
chemin
normal ça va mais quand cette switch
l'embarquent c'est il ya une adrénaline
du direct mais il ya encore une fois je
pense qu'apple est en train d'enlever
mardi jeu ce qu'aurait classe a valent
et le thé je préparais la job est fait
après solares advienne que pourra
mais j'imagine que
j'imagine que au début
cc6 très simplement parce que moi
maintenant je n'imagine pas ce que
surtout
aujourd'hui
c'est tough l'échappée émeutes on le tue
le [ __ ] une fois tout quelque chose pitié
dont six mois je pense tout le temps à
nos bas du mois mais vieux réflexes de
l'ancienne ado
que j'ai encore des fois le défaut de
cette affaire puis je me
suis dit
j'imagine qu'en live aujourd'hui c'est
off quand ben ouais mais il ya quelque
chose d'aussi sécurité ont amené ça fait
une couple d'années que je fais ça
depuis
je ne souhaite jeu qui embarque aussi
puisqu'il souhaite je sais que tu es tu
sais à peu près où est ce que tu te
supplions qui tu parles fait quand tu tu
t'es capable d'établir sa taupe à la
peur d'un échappement une puce est paru
en même temps
je la radio aussi à la soirée est encore
jeune on peut en échappée j'entends
comme une clause de grand-père la soirée
des jeunes ont pu dire visiblement
non c'est je pense que ce passé à 10 ans
qu'on fait ce qu'il sait on est le seul
avec infoman puisse à gagner si on est
les seuls à pouvoir faire ce qu'on veut
et puis
mais vraiment je te dis je te le dis il
ya comme souhaité jean monnet de fait
comme ok je parle à 7 à cet auditoire
l'appui cet auditoire le pire plus c'est
pas tant se changer que juste savoir qui
on parle c'est ce que tu que tu fais
comme transition un moment donné tu
apprécies tu te sens si bien cela dit il
ya des fois tu dis quoi tout
ça très simple d'en tête comme la
logique tant qu'homme du monde sauf que
tu crois tu as le droit de te corriger
de suite après en disant par exemple je
parle des premières nations puis je me
suis trompé en première nation père
fondateur c'est clairement donné comme
tu dis ça se peut se tromper ces fonds
nécessaires au retour de syndicats mais
je me trompe et je veux juste vous dire
de ces pierres précieuses corrige tes
collègues et moi on ne peut pas être
parfait non plus passer morgan qui est
irrémédiable en jeu pas vrai être
ordonnée on vit dans une surtout dans
une époque en ce moment puis je sais je
regardais les jumeaux puis je regardais
avec la diversité avec c'est
l'intégration de des peuples autochtones
et tous ces jeux tout a été mis dans
cette soirée des gémeaux là en concentré
pour nous expliquer un peu ce qui se
passe à la télé parce que je mon grand
pas ma grand-mère qui regarde ce qu'ils
comprennent pas je les comprends ne pas
comprendre c'est parce qu'à un moment
donné tu dis que si ça se passe vite
faut faire une éducation etc et faire
une éducation s'implique aussi accepté
les essais erreurs pour se vendre un bon
endroit peut pas être parfait d'un coup
puis ceux qui pensent que kiki qui sont
qui ont cette mesure est un genre de
plus à décrire en biens pensants sont
que 7 7 vertueux inébranlable es pauvre
est tout le monde fait des erreurs c'est
ce que tu peux tu peux tu peux taper ses
doigts du monde d'entre eux mêmes un
moment donné si pas comme ça tu vas
réussir à faire avancer la société en
général l'om est temps qu'on fait le
parallèle avec moi j'ai pensé à ce
beaucoup de teams chouvier gagnent puis
avec les avec le véganisme je pense
beaucoup parce que il ya beaucoup de
gars qui se place comme étant et quand
même
alors au top de la morale il devient
habitants aussi même moi je l'étais
jusqu'à ce que je me rends compte que
finalement j'ai mangé de la viande
vraiment longtemps la plus grande partie
de ma vie hippie que j'y pensais même
pas avant qui a rien que je fasse un
déclic s'est fait que l'agresseur de
commencer à pointer du doigt les autres
penseurs c'est sa session d'euros
d'actifs pour tout le monde mon grand
père mon grand père je suis dans cette
discussion là dessus
il y est né au saguenay en 1922 cf ville
de l'abbaye dans un endroit où
l'adversité était nul c'est la diversité
qui existe est c'est à dire c'était
blanche c'est à dire qu'il y avait des
norvégiens et tester des marins c'est
parce que c'est une ville portuaire 1922
à la baie on s'en sert je sais comment
fait que lui avec sa ville il ya vécu sa
vie comme ce qui est publié pas bougé de
là ou presque et puis à un moment donné
c'est moi j'ai une des blondes t
haïtienne
je me rappelle de mon grand père c'est
avec des réticences femme annie tu sais
tu peux pas dire ça pas de bon sens
tabarnak
le bonhomme l'oeil à 80 puis même si je
les suive toute ma vie de certains un
meilleur ami tué puis que je je peux
comprendre qu'ils comprennent pas mais
la façon de faire c'est certainement pas
de le trouver cave this tu peux être
surpris tu peux être choqué d'après ce
foot sur place les choses dans son
contexte je me rappellerai tout le temps
la pression ni talent en egypte ensemble
ça et puis j'ai mon grand père est un
instinct c'est un électricien de ces
facs tango tschopp mais c'était aussi un
grand lecteur puisse intéresser beaucoup
beaucoup à l'histoire l'égyptien bien
ordonnée en egypte c'est son premier
voyage à vie avec 80
a été jeudi on était dans un taxi au
caire lopy voyait les godes d'un champ
travail et des djellabas et puis comme
celle dépensée
sur la bonne
pente allons c'est comme si c'est bien
plus sécuritaire et en sandales ça pas
de sens soit estropiés limites et
j'étais la bonne amie à ville de labé en
1922 je peux te garantir que ce non
choix dans sa vie c'est son premier
voyage à 84 à savoir un choc france
correct leurs impressions fraude
l'éducation mais ça peut pas être
parfait d'une chose d'impossible c'est
incroyable ce passé puis hélas
aujourd'hui il est sud est sud est on au
mont houy et les années 50 un petit bout
ça fait ça fait dix ans qu'ils mangeront
leur parti mais que chalet deux ans
avant sa mort à peu près puis avait
jamais voyagé ta vie jamais la m le 1er
mai c'est ça c'est en a donné faut
ouvrir ses horizons il l'a toujours fait
mais un moment donné quand tu es
confronté à ça mais c'est que le petit
un coup tu te rends compte que la
différence existe si elle est pas
nécessairement seulement par rapport à
toi mais elle est au fatigue des autres
qui ont par rapport à 1 face à nous
aussi discret que ya tout ça en même
temps qu'ils mélangent et puis c'est pas
évident pour quelqu'un qui jamais
jongler avec ça dans sa vie parce qu'à
un moment donné tu il lui a pas eu cette
chance là la télé le fait de plus en
plus que je pense que ça va normaliser
pas des affaires mais évidemment que
jacqueline 91 ans et la regarda dvd fois
à peut pas comprendre qu'il faut prendre
les gens par la main c'est important
parce que ça ans ils vont sentir seul il
va voir ce clivage le qui va être encore
plus vivante il faut faire les choses de
la bonne façon mais qui se complique et
jongler toutes les justement là la
polarisation les clivages qui sécurise
un problème mais aussi l'arrêt de la
résistance aux problèmes racisme
problème pythie le complèment problème
que et qui
sont impossibles hiérarchiser m'explique
mans qui sont en même temps tu veux
est décrié pitié critique il est raciste
mais en même temps tu veux aussi c'est
que comprend pas avoir un peu d'empathie
pour ces gens là puis le caecum comment
conjuguer avec
this way au racisme diversité on parle
aussi de pauvreté on parle je pense que
il ya un éveil en fait de deux des
grandes inégalités et puis ça peut être
une égalité sociale c'est au plan
financier c'est au mont par le racisme
au 6b pied puis ben y en a plein
d'autres mais ces inégalités là je pense
que elles ressortent depuis depuis
longtemps mais et ressorte plus je
voudrais depuis une dizaine d'années où
est ce que là on est en train de
constater ces inégalités l'opic de ces
inégalités qui sont diverses et un
moment donné pour être capable de je
pense de les régler mais au moins
atténuer ces inégalités lot il ya un
travail de communauté à papy tout arrive
on a l'impression tout arrive en même
temps si la pandémie en ont donné pas
prévu puis dans cette marche vers le la
progression vers le progressisme ne sais
je pense sincèrement qu'ils étaient il
ya eu ce choc là où ces gens qui étaient
déjà là limite puis on peut voir aux
états unis lé qui t'aiment déjà à la
limite lac avait de la difficulté à
comprendre qu'ils avaient de la
difficulté à saisir leur propre vie et
tout d'un coup deviennent encore une
fois encore plus fragile par des affects
extérieur pile à lyon besoin de prendre
en main quelque chose c'est l'effet que
ça peut être par une campagne anti
vaccins que ça peut être par des doutes
et de la politique du gouvernement ça
peut être devenir conspirationnistes ça
peut être ben des affaires mais à un
moment donné tu es c'est pour ça d'où
l'importance de l'éducation puis
d'expliquer aux gens comme il faut tu
sais sans les prendre
c'est pour des caves mais c'est dur
d'écrire
parce que d'un côté la
simple si on parle encore de convives
puissent encore d'écouter des crises
faites-vous donc actionné fin mai
jean-pierre on va régler après ce mais
en même temps si je veux comprendre
qu'ils ont pareil on demande que pour
toutes sortes de raisons la tille
s'essaye au lion la raison puis on peut
s'en est d'accord et si les comprendre
pour
s'aimer c'est pour ça prend beaucoup de
compassion ça va beaucoup de calme
beaucoup d'écouté fillon donné ça c'est
quand tout le monde est au bout je
voulais exercer toutes les choses que
nbc les choses de ces deux mêmes quand
et fraîche dispo la patience la
compassion angeles et des vertus qui
sont quand même difficile à aller
chercher je pense que c'est des
générations qui sont perdus à quelque
part parce que tu es ceux qui sont
convaincus vont être convaincu jusqu'à
la fin de ses pieds c'est un moment
donné le la job à faire est on a monté
sur l'éducation sur la prise en charge
c'est sûr justement une
compression de ses inégalités locke qui
nous amène à un peu plus de sentiment de
justice c'est parce que c'est le
sentiment d'injustice le pays ces
sentiments d'injustice qui qui exacerbe
à peu près tout ce qui fait que l'on
donné on a comme pas le choix de boeing
comme pas le choix de visites les
problèmes un après l'autre puis c'est
d'être capable de deux de se mettre des
objectifs dans chacun d'eux seuls sauf
que tu es pour quelqu'un qui je prends
l'exemple de mon grand père qui
pour quelqu'un qui jamais eu à jongler
avec ce genre de problème le pick up et
peut-être pas non plus les toutes les
informations pour être capable de le
faire de la bonne façon c'est beaucoup
en même temps c'est la compassion c'est
bien et offre mais je pense qu'on a
comme pas le choix nous
quand tu parles de travail en amont
c'est pipi d'éducation est un exemple
qui me vient en tête moi j'ai grandi
j'ai grandi dans une famille
scientifiques quand même le tipi
louis pasteur comme ticket com qui ont
inventé les vaccins et le dimanche
j'essaie la science et qui n'est jamais
un livre du genre on vous explique louis
pasteur piste quelque chose que avec les
vaccins ça m'a jamais fait peur parce
que je sais comment doux d'où ça vient 2
comment mais j'en ai parlé un petit peu
autour de moi dans les dernières
semaines puis pas beaucoup de monde qui
connaît celui pasteur c'est ça veut dire
que la naissance du vaccin je peux
comprendre que des réticences de quelque
chose que tu content que tu connais pas
du tout puis ça m'a quand même frappé
l'imaginaire dire quelque chose que pour
moi existait depuis tout le temps puis
que celle là de la naissance du vaccin
et puis les processus qui a mené jusque
là depuis le début du 20e siècle était
fait du bien c'est de savoir que c'est
pas tout le monde qui est au courant de
doter le vaccin de la coved c'est
l'accumulation des 100 dernières années
de recherche puis en vaccination le dis
c'est pas nouveau est arrivé dans deux
semaines un pasteur je dirais aussi
quand il a commencé à expliquer que la
solution pour par exemple il ne recule
et où entre
la solution pour éradiquer la rage par
exemple
ça marche qui a sauvé des gens pour
sauver s'il prend un petit garçon qui a
sauvé le tir ils le traînent toute sa
vie et travail et l'institut pasteur
tout un moment donné ça prend des
exemples comme ceux qui partagent leurs
expériences
bien qu'ils font et puis les médecins
font un christine mon travail sur
l'essai sur les réseaux puis yahia mais
encore une fois si le clivage ne se
règlent poste par les réseaux sociaux
puissent pas non plus par trois quatre
phrases bien envoyé qui forment la yole
de quelqu'un d'autre bien qu'on ait
envie que ce soit un chiffre en le
faisant le sait pas ce que la job est
longue pour
thomas guillaume à gramat maternelle est
mort d'une maladie voire 60 en guettant
polio qui aiguise il n'existe plus que
personne ce un grâce au vaccin visant sa
chance et quand celui-ci s'est essayée
premier personne qui vit dans la peur la
polio aujourd'hui exact personne qui m'a
même qui se disent t'as pas d'âme face
dax n'y a personne qui pense maintenant
si la première section tant pis si comme
le fait que ça soit efficace aussi c'est
un peu le le le point faible du son
talon d'achille parce qu'après ça c'est
comme ça
ça devient plus une nécessité ça devient
plus
quelque chose qui me fascine là dedans
c'est que tu es moi me faire vacciner 60
ans mon petit j'ai ma faire vacciner par
pasteur j'aurais été bien plus stressés
on est à la lutte avec ce nations can à
faire vacciner en 2000
on a eu le temps de
renvoyer les gens écoutent et la série
de nick je pense que d'aller l'écouter
c'était faux 5e 2000 puis c'est sûr de
broc qui réalisait ça et c'est sur un
état qui s'appelle la nekba que fin du
19ème début du xxème à new york que j'ai
pu voir de façon très graphique les
avancées de la médecine ça fait cent en
sa faveur à 300 ans et pendant le temps
de louis xiv pc 1001p tu vois juste
comment ça fonctionnait qu'il a jeté les
miracles qui faisait mais avec une chute
il avec tout autre au bout de deux
couteaux longtemps le dit ça fait cent
en fait allé voir ce que dites-vous que
on a eu 100 ans pour développer quelque
chose de complètement miraculeux que ce
soit des vaccins aux opérations
traitement un moment donné faut faire
confiance à ce processus le règle parce
que sinon il ne reste plus rien j'avais
en ligne chez nous mon pari
neurochirurgien mais j'avais un livre
chez nous c'est sûr le premier
neurochirurgien puis il se faisait
appeler le bateau mist en lui ce qui
faisait le soumettant à un trouble dans
tout le trafic il mettait un genre de pk
glace en arcade son sillage il donne un
coup de marteau en dessous clac clac il
ya l'aide du jouet dans quelque chose
tout comme brandao y régler genre
impatient sûr comme louable puisque l'ac
thann déjà un sur dix le qui revenait
correct les nouveautés telles la beauté
musée puis qu'ils étaient capables de
dire leur nom mais c'est fou leur
enseigne de penser que mais c'est ça
ouais ça c'est pas compliqué c'est ça
fait ça fait 100 g pasteur on est en
ça fait cent vingt ans qu'on développe
des vaccins et que ça vole
exemple
c'est intéressant les septs libre apple
qui avait eu un bon impact dans ma vie
charge
alors c'est vrai aussi il ya un an fait
une nouvelle série pleut c'est jean
reyrat contre moi georges st-pierre du
oui oui bien celui-ci leur raconte moi
je vois scarpellino
je te contente de recevoir cette semaine
parce que moi
en fin de semaine c'est mappy crise de
mon programme d'entraînement de la
semaine je fais le marathon du saguenay
samedi j'aime beaucoup mais marathon -
ouais il ya un marathon fjord saguenay
samedi puis là ça fait cinq semaines que
sur le boîtier c'est qu'en ce moment là
je suis bien c'est bien ça quand même
puis la semaine d'après je fais avec
l'équipe de lequin le cadre de 80 les
quatre joints de bromont drouin trop de
bromont pis en sachant contre celui
aujourd'hui j'ai je suis retourné un
petit peu dans les grandes écoles
puis j'ai écouté celui qui te fait avec
matthieu blanchin qui est arrivé
troisième
un rôle trop cruel du mont blanc
c'est complètement incroyable ya plein
d'affaires que je veux parler avec toi
au niveau de l'entraînement le mais
je parlais de parlons de soi parce que
scheckter a été inscrit malgré toi ou
125 de l'americana par bruno blanche non
sous la peau fait on va travailler mais
mais parce que c'est pas quelque chose
que j'ai fait ce jeu j'aimerais ça mais
à vue soit préparé je vais plus jamais
faire des trucs pour préparer j'ai trop
fait de métro
j'ai fait des mains et j'ai fait
beaucoup de compétition
j'ai fait deux marathons pas préparé
puis ça m'a coûté cher puis je veux plus
jamais faire ça mais je trouve ce batman
pinon ce pôle fans c'est pas le fun
après smartphone pendant ce pas le
principal fondant le pana vague acquis
le sens venir aussi le seuil et ya rien
à faire là dedans c'est que je pu faire
ça j'ai plus envie de faire des défis
noir n'ont fait que j'aurais pas été
préparé son qat ici tu me demande de
faire le 25
aucun problème n'a pas été capable
je ne ferai pas en condition parfaite ce
repos mais je serai capable sauf que je
veux faire c'est éventuellement mais je
me rends compte aussi que un quart en a
41 ans c'est plus pareil cas 25 paires
30 puis c'est clair puis aussi j'ai deux
enfants puis j'ai une quotidienne d'été
puis je me rends compte que je fatigue
et on se dit que c'est quand on parlait
un peu de l'horaire je courais pas mal
tous les jours dit c'est sûr que je me
suis rendu compte aussi dans dernières
années que a été quoi je lève mon verre
de vin que mon deuxième verre de 26 puis
relaxés puis je suis un jeune
intermittent mais quand même utile
jusqu'à 8 heures je me permets bain des
affaires puis c'est ça me fait prendre
un peu de poids l'alcool puis je me suis
comme a été quoi qu'est ce que je te dis
je suis rendu là le juge si j'ai besoin
d'être seul je m'entraîne mais je peux
pas fait que la balance fait que pour
aller vraiment aux 80 aux 125 2 km de
trail dans une forme acceptable
ça va falloir que je lâche la
quotidienne d'été pour pouvoir quitter
parce que moi je m'entraîne je me suis
entraîné les tigres vivant je m'entraîne
bien mais c'est pas même à faire des
longues distances jusqu'au bout il m'a
fait chier
j'aime mieux partir longtemps à 18° qu'à
partir longtemps à -10 à fait que ça
pour dire que je pense que j'ai fait mon
deuil d'être capable de ben ouais le oui
par contre
d'un courte distance ou en 42 de trails
oui mais c'est de la plus longue comme
bruno j'ai pas assez de temps enfin bon
vérité
mais moi mais tant
pis je vais te poser la question pour
essayer d'avoir un retour sur
une version future de moi maintenant
c'est sain c'est juste pour moi on
dirait où est ce que je suis en ce
moment moi j'ai eu 30 ans genre 31
janvier pis
moi j'ai fait c'est pas mal plus de main
tendue de la natation de compétition
pilotée transitionner dans la course à
pied dernièrement puis dans la façon que
je veux gérer mon horaire piqué ce que
je veux faire avec mais ton monte en
prime à vie puis les projets que j'ai la
donne et qui semble être celle que je
veux pas bougé c'est le temps que je
veux louée à m'entraîner trois c'est la
chose qui m est on pour mieux vraiment
très très très très peu de contrôles de
l'opportunité que je prendrais ciment
les vrais sam et ont lancé
toi ou est orné avec ce dont je
comprends que la famille c'est différent
parce que par c'est sûr qu'il ya l'année
fonder une famille ce temps les prix
sauf que mettons dans des choix
professionnels
il était écoute je me fais je fais très
peu de compromis pour l'entraînement
dans ce sens où un moment donné tu j'ai
besoin de courir j'ai besoin de courir
quand même entraîné j'ai besoin de
m'entraîner la seule fois dans ma vie où
ça vraiment losciste quand j'ai eu mes
enfants et puis j'en ai eu deux bac à
bac fait néanmoins donné tu es tu fais
choix lopy c'est pas un bon choix puis
je pense que j'apprenais tu piges encore
aujourd'hui qu'hier on est le samedi ça
me dit je suis la radio fait que samedi
je fais un 5 à 7 à radio radio canada en
direct faugère radio canada mais j'ai
mes enfants aussi fait que quand j'ai
mes enfants si je m'organisais que ma
mère puis bon fermé sauf que quand j'ai
mes enfants mais en face on sait si 5050
peut pas les laisser seuls vraiment
facture excuse mais je courais un peu je
fais ce que je fais c'est que je fais
dit j'ai fait 1 5 km le bain strict mais
autour du bloc au téléphone avec mes
enfants c'est jim appelé de temps en
temps
c'est c'est ma façon de faire mais tu
comprends bien que il faisait beau
samedi charest fait en dix ans 12 on va
donner il ya un deuil à faire c'est de
l'irréel cpie jeu ce qui fait que bon tu
compenses de journée outre pas d'enfants
mais au fil du temps
laisse toujours de la place pour
l'entraînement mais c'est peut-être que
tu vas être capable de garder en train
compétences humaines profondes
dans dames après je monte à peu près
100 kg fait qu'il garde un genre de
design de renault s'est dit ça ça reste
toujours sa chère entre 7 et 10 agents
c'est beaucoup là c'est en temps dont
nous le quintette des enfants qui vont à
l'école des lunch ptt s'est beaucoup le
message un mois maintenant et comme
quelque chose d d d d d mais
heureusement des trucs quand même si je
monte à 25 ans je sais que sam animaux
plus jamais de ma vie c'est pas grave
c'est aimer l'autre fois je travaille
moins puis je vais être capable de
clencher dans ma semaine
t125 cherchant seul type ça ça me
rendrait un 12
c'est du stock la ccfl 12 heures par
jour après le tir le jeudi 12 g
demandons ces deux heures par jour
mais mais cela dit c'est quelque chose
qui est possible parce que j'ai vraiment
moins de stock puis je vais en prendre
moins puis j'ai besoin de ces temps là
parce que je sais que je pourrai
m'impliquer pour faire d'autres choses
mais j'ai six mois pour m'entraîner 5
fait que je veux le faire fonctionner
comme ce jour partir mon était en chef
puis 5
quelque chose pour toi qui est un défi
c'est de trouver c'était qui les bleus
de genre être capable de m'entraîner à
ses capés de doléances et à mes enfants
un cap à décider sourit sur la job but
they j'essaie de jeu même genre de
pression au look éthique etc en tant
qu'ex tartelettes on se met un peu toute
l'année en tant que
quelques types performance peu trop
c'est comme qui temouchent fait mouche
même objectif mais ton jeu pratiqué
d'autres lecteurs de ma journée
m'entraîner une donnée travaux du temps
avec ma blonde s'est fait travailler la
draille dans le podcast ravi nancy
travailler dans ce procès comme des fous
chantants intelligent reçus dernièrement
jeter un point je me levais le matin
mettais comme ce récit de ma journée
quelques mceachran est capable de tout
faire ce que je veux faire planer c kom
sa puissance il faut comme de
magnifiques et
non seulement sortir mais tu peux pas
être bon moment donné des affaires que
tu si je vais être bon parent tu veux
être un bon parent qui c'est chouette un
bon animateur mais abandonnée il ya le
principe du
c'est du 80/20 cette saga tires tu en es
le dernier vingt pour cent tu t'amènes
vers la perfection te coûte trop de
risques c'est exact ça mon sens et et il
leur faut que cesse des choix de ces
impies ces choix là c'est l'eau qui sont
les plus difficiles à puis je te parle
comme si je t'en veux ça je les vois
je j'ai beaucoup de culpabilité quand je
m'entraîne pas g il ya bien des affaires
qui qui tourne autour de quelques la
culpabilité chez moi du collectif puis
que ce soit les enfants conçus avec la
job mais un moment donné il faut c'est
possible de faire plein d'affaires mais
tu peux pas être excellent dans tout
fait comme on dit fait des choix si je
pense que je m'en sors bien à job je
pourrais être encore meilleur mais un
moment donné si je veux être encore
meilleurs ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
que je mette de côté l'entraînement puis
que je mette de côté puis ça devient une
obsession le je m'entraîne et met un peu
de côté mes enfants puis meti qua non
moi je suis content chanceux je dois
être bon je me force et je veux tout
temps être leur être professionnel mais
j'essaie samman et sa rétine je
recherchais les lettres que je place
dans cette contrée trouve ça me
coûterait bien trop cher par exemple est
drôle charmante est aussi jugée bonne
machine je peux dire des gens qui dans
ce milieu là qu'ils sont capables d'être
extravagants ces banques sont capables
d'être dans l'extrême c'est un jeu j'en
vois je ne peux pas face au jeu peut
paraître comme si je peux pas être si je
peux être exigeant mais mam n'est pas au
prince dans l'extrême maigreur exigences
avec eux dans leur travail tout et puis
je sais qui
on cite souvent les julie snyder de ce
monde ses pieds un moment donné je
pourrais pas être comme ça je peux pas
être comme ça j'ai pour la constitution
pour être comme ça je peux pas faire ça
s'est fait comme on est tous l'acceptent
ça combine j'espère que ça va
fonctionner longtemps avec le plus
d'effort possible de ma part
professional et simply d'exposer le peu
de talent que j'étais pour être capable
de conscience par l'autre meetic g mais
on a donné ses cheveux pull choix fin
mais ce problème est que moi je trouve
ça tellement à tort parce que
moi je suis probablement la personne la
plus combative que je connaisse me tonti
publicité ce qui faisait ma force qu'un
juge
pour être un haut niveau en natation
c'était pas mal ce qui me démarquer des
autres c'était ça le fait quand ça c'est
fini
malheureusement la compétitivité en moi
et pas disparu la nuit n'ont fait que
l'homme et ont moins dit j'ai commencé à
courir puis je pas vrai que tu es mon
premier marathon j'ai fait trois heures
37 puis j'ai marché les ravitaillements
dans le dernier des sinistrés puis je me
suis dit pauvre est le sport avec cc
c'est sûr pour moi le site peut pas
accepter excepté cela en plus de monde
le reconnaissait pis ils criaient let's
go quand je marche un ravitaillement
comme ce pauvre ex et c'est la fin pour
seul s'est fait qu il va toujours avoir
quelque chose puis même chose pour le
pur pour le podcast le ti de se
contenter d'un podcast qui fonctionne
comme du monde sait que non même si je
veux pas me contenter de ceux d'un ange
convient plutôt de ma vie tpiy c'est sûr
que moi j'ai pas l'aspect le typhus et
le batteur puis pas d'enfants dans les
sujets jugés comme j'ai dû quand même
beaucoup tard la place de la faiblesse
mais je me vois pas mes temps ne plus
avoir cette espèce d'affaires la moitié
moins ça c'est of quality je pense qu'à
un moment donné je pense que tu n'aies
avec surtout mourir exxon ça c'est clair
cela dit un moment donné
des infections habitants
j'aime juste et ça ne m'est jamais la
scène politique il y 10 43 puis il ya
envie d'avoir des enfants que des tirs
retentissaient animant rissman séjourné
six pitié d'argent ça vole ça me fait
bien rire c'est de penser que c'est
parce que je disais tiens on va donner
toute liberté de détente c'est toute la
vie quand tu vas avoir des enfants
randonnée ils apprennent afrique vont
sauter puis c'est moi des fois je pense
je te regarde comme un dieu le temps
qu'il a mais ça arrive jamais que je
pense que c'est une pensée je pense que
c'est un moment tu vois ce que tu as
envie ce temps à lomé jeu je changerai
pas je m'ennuie pas du tout je m'ennuie
pas
00 même si j'aspire à ce verre de vin
autour d'un thé gamme puis j'aimerais ça
avoir du temps soit mais ça dure points
2 secondes nice crée que c'est tout du
temps c'est cool tu l'as pas menée sur
l'europe et leur plus fort repli pour
c'est vraiment pas si rochant la face à
la fois qu'il rechante c'est ton ta
relation avec l'entraînement puis avec
le kit est ta culpabilité
si je te cache pas pour moi c'est ça
qu'il qui le défient je pense que ce
grand défi de de te sentir bien même si
je t'ai pas entraîné de t'ouvrir une
bien même si t'as pas dépenser 120
calories précédemment pour justifier que
tu bois 7 via lé 6 cesse tout cela
découle de tam dont la capacité à être
bien avec toi même mais c'est un travail
c'est la job mais est ce que tu penses
que
c'est un chemin qui est
absolument qui nécessairement
souhaitable de se décharger de cette
culpabilité bah oui parce que moi cette
culpabilité l'homme ç'a vraiment
beaucoup moins parce que moi je
fonctionne au défi je fonctionne au au
battage de thé a raté mon propre qpi si
j'ai pas maintenant si j'ai pas cette
culpabilité le des fois je là des fois
même je me l'imposent le titre des fois
comme l'avait fait un défi de 112 jours
ccsa semaine vers vrai marathon puis je
voulais le mettre ces réseaux sociaux
parce que je voulais me corriger car
enfin fait que chaque fois que je me
sentais pas bien pour y aller mais je me
sentais mal en tabarnak de paul fort
puis j'y allais quand même subi au final
quand je finissais ce la culpabilité qui
m'avaient amené à le faire quand ça
finisse et c'était le moment d'extase
complet de comme lost ou sur tout c'est
le culpabilité là dans la journée ou
est-ce que tu me diras crise une grosse
journée je pourrais pas le faire
finalement j'y allais mais servat lui
l'appétit bah oui avec moi je cherche
pas nécessairement amende est chargé
maintenant je pense que c'est un je
pense que c'est un fonctionnement qu'il
faut encore une fois le ct je juge
popsci mais je pense que c'est un
fonctionnement qu'il faut défaire c'est
à dire que être capable d'aller
s'entraîner et être satisfait
sans avoir besoin de passer par la
culpabilité c'est quand même un objectif
noble c'est d'être capable de ne pas
avoir besoin de torrents de bois pour
ton monte fake ton but moi ce serait mon
but aussi têtue elle l'est encore
aujourd'hui c'est quand je vais courir
je vais courir puis ça me rend heureux
je finis je suis content puis si j'ai
pas envie de courir que j'ai pas sorti
des fois c'est utile de se voter le tube
d'y aller lui absolument absolument mais
des fois c'est aussi être capable des
sciences po non ce sera possible d'un
point puis être allée saint piat mon
avis à mon avis si on est capable de
laisser aller la culpabilité au final on
va arriver à la même forme physique tout
simplement parce que l'attention tu mets
sur cette culpabilité la source parce
qu'on va donner ça se peut pas que ça
que ce que ça prend un coup sous
le le va-et-vient du jugement en veux je
me récompense je m'en veux juste
récompense parce que tu as un moment
donné si on y est on est des animaux oui
mais on n'est pas des animaux sauvages
qui fait que t on pas que fonctionne t
on un cerveau qui est assez développé
pour être capable de ne pas avoir besoin
de travailler sur sur le sur la
récompense seulement un moment donné
faut parfois être capable de savoir que
si on fait quelque chose c'est parce que
ça nous rend bien et heureux points sans
avoir eu besoin de nous prouver que le
contraire nous rendait malheureux
société cette dualité de mon dieu c'est
l'histoire d'une ville
aussi en ce moment je l'entraînement
dans ta vie
aujourd'hui ces maisons au top l'alizé
priorité abdelali des choses importantes
mais c'est en deuxième troisième
position tu as tout à cette culpabilité
leur piquer sa d autre chose qui va
payer mais
devrait plus importante à vis pas un
problème c'est dur ça marche prieux peau
de ya pas de conséquences négatives ou
fait que tout envie d'entraîner le temps
pour le faire et aujourd'hui tout cas
mal et ça prend trop plate puis il ya
une obsession se souvient plus poussé
que justice était ma blonde a pas
d'enfant c'est puis
pour rencontrer mes enfants puis à vis
depuis longtemps seuls les solitaires
succès qui
j'aimerais un chien s'est dit
j'ai des enfants puis ma maison est
propre du mieux que je peux et organique
qu'est ce que tu veux j'aime des
enjambées dans sa
salle a fait virer folle des fois tu
piges dans une roulotte et puis ma
roulotte et c'est une petite roulotte le
stream c'est
szpiner
j'ai deux enfants en chine ces styles
puis honda n'était cette volonté ou 7
o'clock qui tue c'est ça le monde si
c'est ça je comprends mais un moment
donné pour laisser aller pointer un pipi
je pense que ça qu'est kim quand tu es
quand des poignets pour ça c'est à dire
que
même des enfants le petit lev le matin
déjà les reconduire matin l'école plus
je revenais chimie ou de ses pigistes et
je me retrouvais dans mon lit un sujet
mal dormi le tabarnak jour nos jours je
vais m'entraîner il logerait paul est
important il faut que je parte chez nous
puis est parti de chez nous pour venir
ici le puis j'ai regardé le salon puis
regardez la cuisine je regarde des
photos
même année faut-il espoirs christopher
année ça va le ceseda priorité moi je
lui ai donné ma priorité juste partie
mon ex est enceinte puis de mon premier
puis c'était mon année où je faisais
deux mains en or une fois par semaine
qu'ils la souhaitent encore jeunes une
fois par semaine puis si j'avais une
super bonne paye je travaillais
littéralement trois jours puis n'ai pas
d'enfant aymen je m'entraîne elle aussi
tout ce que j'avais à faire qui c'était
fantastique c'était fantastique mais je
pense que ça a coûté quelque chose aussi
à ma blonde c'est de l'époque parce que
tu es man était tellement concentré là
dessus de ce que tu viens un peu fou lui
tu le sais gloire
bon c'est pas un ami afin qu'ils
tiennent pas la route le théâtre peut
pas voir est un coupé des enfants est ce
une job ça se peut pas c'est clair qu'un
choix puisque avec le meilleur choix tu
peux garder soi mais un choix ouais
quand je
te mets ton par la natation je sais
c'est quoi être élite qui fait qu'un
homme étrange
je commence à obséder un petit peu gros
sur ces affaires loeb je regarde mes
stats puis je me dis aux élites wright
façon vraiment récréative était correct
mais tes petits c'est parce que tu sais
où est ce que tu étais où est-ce que tu
étais capable d'aller c'est ce qu'ils
revoient mais celle aussi où est ce que
les autres sont puis capable de muter de
comparer mais dont tilt inscrits dont
n'importe quelle course que tu fais tu
t'inscris puis un peloton élite en avant
d'enter voix paul non c'était non des
voix pas une seconde je vous parle de
tout en même temps après le premier
virage des voies plus les beautés lui le
titulaire mais c'est ça c'est sur place
et aussi avec kate ont croupi un médium
qui disait en vélo m c'est un sport
d'humilité le vélo la course aussi ce
qui est toujours quelqu'un de plus vite
que toi tout le temps on importe surtout
le temps de rencontrer ça arrivera
jamais que tu vas être le plus de la
viande une fois mais cette fois leur
voiture et qu'un second pas fini après
examen qui valait près de quatre au
factuel l'espoir d' humilité même plan
d'adaptation ça m'a fait tilt il est
tout le temps que s'il ya quelqu'un
quand même plus vite que toi
littéralement rien tu peux faire rien tu
peux comme c'est pas comme étant michael
beasley les notes d'aisé pas le sortir
battu la russie c'est comme une fois sur
dix y laisser tout le monde ensemble il
ya une affaire qui se passe à ce moment
là dedans et sport comme ça ça existe et
c'était au golf peut faire un coup comme
tiger woods une fois leur en laisse pas
d'endurance malheureusement ces plats
mais ces sautes fait le meilleur votre
le tango réglages se peut parier mettons
aux olympiques en 2008 je mets de
l'argent sur michael phelps tu gagnes
c'est grave et hier c'était le meilleur
qu'est ce tu veux c'est ça c'est ça le
secret que c'est vraiment d'espoir qui
t'oblige je trouve à mettre en contexte
et puis surtout quand tu es prêt il est
un peu importe le sport c'est plus
toujours t'améliorer c'est clair sauf
que le temps que ça prend tir pour moi
quand je faisais déjà le même litige je
calculais le diplomate estime enfin juin
à 23 semaines puis regardez le plus je
me disais bon là je pas bon en natation
les phares que ça me prend pour
améliorer la notation de une minute et
demie deux minutes sur trente minutes
tellement prendre de temps alors que je
peux m'améliorer a coursé au vélo pour
beaucoup moins de temps et beaucoup plus
développée et demi gagner fait c'est ce
que je faisais avec un moment donné il
faut savoir où est ce que tu es dans
côté bon psy mais encore une fois
j'aimerais peut-être la tige et moi je
suis pour des juges après on connaît que
j'ai vraiment appris à me connaître bien
vraiment le cac 40
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
juste où
il ya eu quelque chose petit je me
sépare et j'étais père monoparental la
moitié du temps antilles puis
m'a mené
6 1 j'ai toujours été du juge au déficit
dans ma vie mais si puis lecture pic à
nice pis y'a vraiment conne mais j'ai
depuis depuis un an pour longtemps mais
depuis un an mais à peu près là je
prends le temps ce que je faisais jamais
dans ma vie depuis un arbre et je sais
où je me situe dans tout connaître ses
forces et ses faiblesses notées
ggg compris put aller passer des tests
j'ai compris où est ce que je me situe
et et j'aime j'ai clairement 1h pays ok
tu détestes lâche plus ça s'appelle très
bon
potentiel intellectuel qui
puis il a mené comme ça te replaces
parce que tu étais capable de dire par
qui mon comportement demande c'est pour
ça mon comportement demande si c'est pas
seulement comme parce qu'on va donner
quand fiabci plus que tu dis moi mais je
fais ce que je ressens ce plus facile à
christie s'exclamer problème dit il ya
en a 800 puis c'est pas trop
c'était pour commettre règle en même
temps avec le titan voluptueux comme
hostilités il ya tellement la fin de
l'année tu sais pas où deux places et
qui sait pas comment régler qui ont tant
donné je suis j'ai passé c'était un de
mes amis qui n'est pas si c'était cela
puisqu'ils ce qui est une voisine 5t
comme on est pareil tu y fais que ça va
aider le départ c'était cela le titre à
dire bon ok clairement aidé à faire que
du catch plus vite que les autres ça
donne pas davantage au contraire il faut
se donner des avantages puis dans ta vie
personnelle amoureuse personnel
professionnel s'il ya bien des affaires
qui sont impactés puis quand j'ai
compris ce que j'ai lu ce risque comme à
ok me donner un break sur certains trucs
même accepté sur d'autres
puis je vois m'a aidé à avancer avec
ceux ci fais ça me prises pour mieux me
comprendre à certains égards est aussi
une autre affiche une gorgée d'eau
un des bons jobs m'a initié à une
affaire débile mais de fumer un cigare
puis
prend d'une heure et demie ta soirée
pour faire une chose telle offre mais
c'est long fins canaris 23h59 heure et
demie lors des x 2 puis
j'aime ce lait par des romans des trucs
que je me suis informé jamais si toi
puis tout s'est dit mais je faisais tout
le temps de quoi je fais tout le temps
de quoi d'inviter tout le temps tout en
invitant tout en qui j'avais jamais de
break puis le côté hp m'aide à
comprendre pourquoi tu parce que j'aime
je me sais que tu la musique mais j'en
écoutais puis la musique parce que moi
ce que je voulais c'était
à prendre que des podcasts d'histoire
tulle et des livres audio exact fait
mouche comme donner moins de
l'information parce que si j'ai une
heure à rien faire je me sentirais pas
en fait je veux hein je veux qu'on me
remplissent le cerveau de quelque chose
c'est que j'écoutais des podcasts ou le
terrain tout le temps tout le temps une
tête et est constamment
sollicité mais je savais pas trop
pourquoi mais j'ai toujours été membre
pendant tout le temps que je m'en allais
au mexique que je vais en faire jeu égal
au mexique avec des amis qui ma blonde
de l'époque puis
jeté sa plage les autres prenant un
verre josette me faisaient courir
j'écoute un podcast d'histoire de ces
faits que je me suis claqué genre toute
l'histoire de napoléon pendant que je
dors guerre parce que je me disais
associé au moins je change ans mais
moment profitez de faire de quoi pour
moi de jouer à prendre sûrement pas les
11 accusés faculté comme fait qu'à un
moment donné ça vient que ça prendrait
pis quand tu comprends pourquoi d'où ça
vient puis pourquoi battue d'un débreak
s'appelle aussi apte à mener ailleurs ça
peut être aussi hâte accepté puis le
cigare fait que ait sais quoi je
m'assois pendant une heure puis je suis
obligé je peux écouter un peu de cash
peut lire mais tissot pendant une heure
et demie ces rachats
mais quand tu rentres là dedans ça comme
au hockey ça se peut
ça m'a aidé beaucoup pour beaucoup sur
la méditation
c'est exactement sur mer un exercice de
respiration oui je sais ça me fait
vraiment penser
je vais encore amené au sport mais pour
un pour illustrer le ce que tu viens de
dire le
camp mais deux dernières années de
natation je faisais mon propre programme
d'entraînement puis on le monte en
conjointement avec notre entraîneur de
l'époque mais on était un petit groupe à
d'avoir décidé ce qu'on faisait vraiment
basée sur la science puis ouest qui
était rendu plantations ce sport quand
même arriérés le pilon voulait amener ce
vraiment et les dernières découvertes
puis on bat notre programme sur ce puits
une des affaires qui étaient là la clis
de la polarisation d'entraînement ça
veut dire que tu fais des séances
des séances intenses vraiment intense
mais que la séance d'après ce une séance
de récupération c'est
frustrant comment qu'il faut que sois
relaxe russe 30
puis ce moment le camp que dans la
pensée la natation de faire ainsi 1000 m
relax mais comme sur du pays zone 45 200
m pour ceux qui savent que ça va pour
des nageurs d'excellence il lance un
sacrement puis dans l'ancienne pensé
c'était en train de perdre ton temps
mais ce que ça faisait réellement secte
assimilés l'entraînement de la veille
dans ton entraînement tu l'as compris
entraînements que tu faisais d'entente
telle est la simuler après ce but allait
confirmer que razak et avait fait de la
veille bref pour ce genre d'affaires la
maintenant moi maintenant je faisais un
peu sur tout le temps chaque fois que je
faisais de la route j'écoutais pas de
cas chaque projet allait courir
j'écoutais des podcasts de 6 est de
gagner de la connaissance mais tu l'as
6000 jamais vraiment temps que je prends
pas la peur d'arrêter exemple d'être
questionné sur qu'est ce que tu viens
d'apprendre hier je revenais du
bas-du-fleuve pas mais j'ai fait quatre
heures de charge puis j'ai pas écouté
rien je me suis juste parler je me parle
à voix haute dans mon charme c'est
sophie réfléchi sur la bref du problème
soulevé de trucs j'essaie de réfléchir à
voix haute sur des concepts que j'ai
appris que j'ai commencé à aborder dans
une conversation avec avec du monde la
veille pile tu fais juste parler de
turin puis on dirait que ça aille
vraiment à comme
concrétiser la connaissance puis à la
sainte et 10 et puis après ça être
capable de l'expliquer on pas souvent
gabriel nadeau dubois ont leur celui-ci
deux fois comment il est capable de tuer
pose une question qui va te l'expliquer
comme si c'est une dissertation dix mois
de mars a été tiré le pti c'est sûr que
lui prend la peine d'arrêter de faire
son choix tu sais ça puis puis ça je
trouve cgt puis prochain que le cigare
te permet de faire sur le tir et ça ce
wee cc conçu parce que c'est tout à fait
vrai ce que tu dis tu sais l'homme la
comparaison que le sport est très bonne
parce que encore une fois tu mathieu
le guilly fed et l'ultra trail une
vitesse folle série
la plupart du temps quand il va
s'entraîner gens n'aiment pas que des
groupes de course du dimanche parce
qu'ils vont trop vite
avant qu'ils montent justin c'est
impressionnant comme mai mais je sais
comment ça se fait que tu es capable
d'augmenter au niveau bas de ses
entraînements spécifiques même temps
quand je fais des mises entraînement
relaxe il va très très lentement
dick des fous et courtes diminue ouais
un gros 10h10 puis il fait comme ce
correctif au
concept là de tout le temps dans la
performance vers la performance encore
une fois tu y es elle demanda à prendre
son temps c'est pour s'améliorer mais
encore une fois c'est dur à accepter
c'est frustrant et seat algérie foot
comme je dis si j'ai fait j'ai fait de
la psychanalyse pour apprendre ou de ma
vie j'en pendant huit mois puis un
moment donné mon cher jamais fait seul
de ces pays reste un de mes bons hommes
qui
secoue ce canal et puis on tend pandémie
s'est fait que c'était trois fois
semaine trois fois en veilleuse ou mail
à web qui je les fait 8 mois tient bien
en donner je voudrais commencer lopy
j'ai un jeu ghost et maxi parce que je
pense m'apprête à pouvais plus c'est
quand
une journée break le faire un mois de
break faculté j'ai senti dans dix ans je
sais qu'il faut que je sois je
recommence mais j'ai besoin d'une
perspective c'était trop ça va à
l'encontre des psychanalystes ou la
psychanalyse disposait comme insistant
au point où cette loge pas de type ça
fait sortir plein d'enfants mais cela
dit quand tu étais dans quelque chose
c'est dur de prendre le temps de savoir
ce qui s'est passé et puis comment tu le
vis qu'il eut commencé l'analyse et ça
prend du temps tir puis mais c'est dur à
accepter une erreur je le cigare je te
dis mais c'est quelque chose ça peut pas
le dire on peut pas dire que ça va mais
hier ce rituel le
dur explique s comme un bon vin prendre
le temps oui mais j'ai un ami qui me
disait que souvent ce soit resté après
sous-payés mettront s'ouvrait
souveraineté de 26e sera de 20 écoutez
un peu de musées qui prenait sa guitare
gratter de trop à faire mal et j'obtiens
déjà jusqu'à profiter de la vie relax et
faire lire à face qui s'étend de fer sur
le moment puis j'avais qu'aucun plan aux
carriers je télécharge fait jamais aussi
j'ai fait jamais ce site ultra organisés
de keita la terreur sont fort simples
habitants je vais aller au jump les
nanas qui gère finalement tu te couches
plus que jamais l'outil ce moment-là de
juste de nom de processus et puis juste
et comme de deux faces que tel aviv face
sur les pulsions des études mais c'est
dur de se laisser ce temps l'autre dans
la société auquel on vit en ce moment je
trouve qui s'étoffe de se laisser ce
temps à l'appui dont on peut en parler
le 5 juillet comme un monde j'en ai dit
vers 100 milliards mais je pense qu'on
demande la performance aussi bon demande
l'excellence pire moment donné ça sam ça
vient ça vient
c'est juste pas été confronté de façon
assez frontal
nos désirs et nos envies
multifacettes c'est comme tu peux pas
être performant dans toutes les monnaies
cécile sujet comptes dont on parle
depuis
2006 la ville ne te fait pas j'aime noms
n'ont découvert ce petit ange
il ya deux types de sports un lieu du
sport d'entraînement cependant durant ce
qui est du parc de loisirs
quand on ne peut pas comparer la rocky
le golf à la course au vélo à la marge
et les sports que tu dis jouer
maintenant jouer au hockey c'est ça
s'est toujours pas fait de vélo
la limite c'est un jeu comme si je
faisais c'était court mais scam mais je
joue pour accourir pour ces faits que je
vais pas faire d intervalle je
passe les gens qui
sont en train de jouer au soccer en acte
et je joue au football au soccer de ses
puits jouanno mais mais mais je rappelle
ce pas mais ma femme non je trouve que
c'est vraiment pas même en fait dans ma
tête à moitié aller jouer au hockey si
on même niveau que d'aller jouer à des
jeux vidéo ou aller jouer à des jeux de
société dans le principe dans ce que sa
cause est encore
de santé puis pour beaucoup de monde je
pense c'est la chose que le fait que tu
vas jouer peut-être en firent pas
content que tu en train de rentrer est
entraînée par un peu l'impression que je
faisais exactement
c'était bouger sans a l'impression de
bouger mais mme et à la question mon
rapport je
faisais pas ça moi je t'ai tout leur
mentent et arrêter de te fait selon
l'ansés avec l'annotation limite si
jamais
j'ai découvert ce jeu christie je me
rends compte que ça fait plus longtemps
que je m'entraîne que tu t'entraînes
quelques jeunes en train de pau me fait
pas longtemps ça fait un choc face à 20
ans 21 ans et que je pourrais faire du
bcp avoir mal au mal pour la même baisse
face à fait ça fait vingt ans avant
j'avais jamais aucune des compos
dépenses et des limites de nos vies ça
va ouais c'est
tout d'abord mal dans le fond c'est ça
c'est que a expliqué cécile a expliqué
1 ce point là c'est pourquoi le tir
c'est vrai qu'il étoffe pied parce qu'à
un moment donné je pense que la
satisfaction se prétend que tu es mal
qui est de savoir que tu en avais plus
que tu pensé
c'est la limite est dépassée à l'image
de didier a écrit steve peux pas croire
que ça allait mon nom et mon temps
glacis j'ai fait beaucoup de baisser
qu'au début de ma de ma vie de sportif
le
pmc j'ai eu la chance d'aller faire les
alpes c'est la foi qui
la première photo seul si je tue montre
excellent du monde ce moment dans une
vie c'était jeudi 6 à rien dit d'autre
fait jpy qui si l'homme est un clin
d'oeil le comparer à auzat tu sais ça
dure 1h30 temps de monter interminable
le camp du monde pitt arrive au bout de
bain j'aurais pas cru que je me serais
rendu parce qu'au premier coupé
d'architectes et qui aurait fait le
changement au genre vient poser enfin
que ce sentiment là je peux pas le
connaître tant que pas été poussés à la
limite mais pour te pousser à la limite
c'est rare que tu fais volontairement
soutien tu fais vraiment permanent
cependant durant cette gc en sept
semaines d'expliquer à des amis pourquoi
je faisais pour que je m'étais inscrit
aux 80 de bromont et d'expliquer
pourquoi de vie en essayant de le
verbaliser j'ai réalisé que je n'étais
pas capable de le verbaliser je t'ai pas
capable d'expliquer pourquoi précis
comme mais je veux juste me prouver
qu'elle est capable de le faire que le
haut mais tu sais que tu es capable de
le faire fait oui mais tant que je le
fais prophète on dirait que je me crois
pas capable de le faire mathieu
blanchard il dit c'est pour pour ceux
qui nous écoutent qui on l'a mentionné
tantôt le trottoir du mont blanc c'est
comme le super bowl du le trottoir exact
c'est la grosse afrique mathieu
blanchard est un français
adoptée
qui habitent ici à montréal il est
arrivé troisième c'est un exploit
complètement incroyable puis lui disait
dans ces affaires là qui est en un sens
ce sont 10 km autour du mont blanc est
dit dans ces épreuves là après 20
kilomètres ceux qui disent ton podcast
d'après 20 km j'ai les jambes source de
vie à partir de là c'est là que le
travail commence c'est s'imagine dessus
c'est
son premier 20 km les faits à 1h30 en
plus il est ce le plus attendu qu'il
faut un fonds de trois autres en
fait que cette espèce de gratification
loin d'être capable de quand tu penses
que
quand je pense que tu peux que tu dois
arrêter l'exode continue maintenant
c'est super compliqué vie j'ai été j'ai
bien des souvenirs là d'un moment où
j'allais arrêter si j'ai des images
claires de boutoir ce que je voulais
arrêter mais j'ai continué et si j'ai
cette image photographique ac c'est
clair dans la tête de puits des âmes tu
dois avoir en plus le panorama qui te
revient en tête le cas exactement dans
cette revue le chef quand ces actifs les
alpes le titre fait ça pour le fun enfin
c'est autant passer des vacances j'étais
pris dans le congèle factice et pas de
ligne d'arrivée
c'est d'autant plus tough thé mais tu
continues pis c'est le café en eau la
petite bière oued et
une fois ci sortant comme un système de
récompenses l'a16 mais toutes faites
chalenge et deux fois par du monde
autour du genre pourquoi tu fais ce
qu'est ce qui te pousse à quand je
m'entraînais comme un débile oui mais
avant aïe il ya dix ans par ma foi que
maintenant je dix ans
je pense que l'entraînement est quelque
chose de normal maintenant c'est quelque
chose d'accepter les gens qui courent se
pose est comment ce côté j'étais très
malade je pense que ceci étant bgc note
mais il ya dix ans maintenant il ya dix
ans choisir un thème par semaine puis
j'étais petit j'étais juste un kurde la
cgt littéralement est le jouet à
175 milles 180 je faisais 156 accepter
ou rejeter maigre
la crise les gens me regardent et
réseaux comme à deux fautes
l'autodafé cambodge dont celle où j'ai
sauté
quand en touche pas que thomas quand tu
compares jeudi notamment du monde
meilleur puis finalement te fais pas ça
pour moi c'est le meilleur qui fait ce
juste pour te dépasser toi mais du moins
qui était le meilleur dans quelque chose
s'est pas démentie par météo - c'est
comme ta job aussi en même temps c'est
plié tandis que là c'est clairement été
le il ya pas de bénéfices autre que
juste comme le sentiment de la famille
rien de rien de rien et au lycée j'étais
à 155 n'est pas super et en chèques mais
pensante est nécessairement
puisque piqué leur gorge je dis pas non
plus pour la validation extérieur parce
que votre monde sans sac aussi
clairement max et de la validation
extérieur dans ta petite gang de
sportifs
d'autres choses que ce soit et je mets
devenir un des nôtres si je me souviens
des temps relativement meilleurs
monsieur montant notre jeu on était
débile le team et s'est séparé puis je
vais t'expliquer main à main
encore une fois on est une gang à faire
sur le train pin bangagné faire sopi
dans mag anja paerson qui m'a battu ces
facs logement souvient encore de tout
sauf que t'est ce ils se montrent même
patrice était capable de
2,6 remettent en fait de le faire en
compétition il battrait sur le soutien
mais il fait pas que je m'en souviens
c'est un fait qu'on met 500
kg fin du monde du marathon le dans bon
nombre des miens notamment des pirates
ont chuté dans une pente trop classique
ils savent même pas si quoi que ce soit
par des non c'était pas ça veut rien
dire à personne
ce que quand j'ai fait tellement ma
dernière compétition
organisée c'est 121 km en arizona
dans une treille d'un puits
puis gagnant de la bo pis j'avais jamais
fait de trail de ma vie littéralement
c'est du belge de nive réussi à niveler
en salle
très complexe et esthétique le groupe
bull pi
vraiment contente j'ai fait je suis pas
bon tant pis je tiens j'en reviens pas
encore que je teste aussi jeter siècle
achetée en jetant forme puis faites aux
femmes mais c'était le 6 mars 2020 je
suis revenue le 13 mars 2005 fiche de
direction au début début de la pandémie
puis ses effectifs est que sauf télphone
dit judith mais c'était le fun si c'est
pas cette couette répit montant oui mais
il y avait d'autres aussi il y avait la
vue il y avait les traits pierre bel le
faire à l'extérieur qui sont là
c'est moi je le comprenais pas du tout
ce que moi mettons est en est que je te
dans le temps à l'excellence mettons le
joyel monde qui faisait genre d iron man
récréatif quelqu'un ils sont des fils de
genk vous êtes malade vous n'êtes pas
bon dom22 vous vous êtes
contents de payer des bike à 12 mai le
piège pour triper avec sue fait le
letchi là une fois que je passais
l'autre bord j'ai comme eric compris sur
ce que tu veux dire les deux comme
j'ai fait deux fois le marathon de
québec c'est comme c'est le fun parce à
travers toutes les cartes si québec il
ya plein de monde qui sont là qui
encourage pilote de du monde qui se
dépasse avec toi le monde pleure en
arrivant puis c'est beau c'est trippant
ccbbo soins puis c'est ça c'est trouver
le bon là dedans tu pas juste le
côté compétitif s'est retrouvé le
beaucoup moins quand tu le lot est
contente j'imagine aussi c'est sûr que
ça amène aussi des bénéfices sais pas
encore ce que l'on encense que c'est ça
qui est d'habitude un jour de faire de
ta vie ça amène quelque chose de faire
du sport inévitablement le fait de faire
du port de manta de possibles problèmes
en autant de talent faire
court et que je l'aimé de sétif là
dedans puis quelque chose c'est comme
impulsif a aussi maintenant aussi de 1,2
des processus d'affaires puis un
apprentissage sur soi saas et cloud de
spezza a ses limites il ya un
apprentissage mais dit entend parler de
l'aide l'équilibré le tien m c'est quand
ça dépasse c'est que ça comment ni quand
le vase est trop plein le sait ça cool
saison et ça marche pas c'est sûr c'est
cela la job dans vie c'est d'être
capable de trouver un équilibre sain qui
est tout penses tu mets ton que le fait
de faire du sport
ça fait peut-être de toi un meilleur
rythme at on vous en parlera pas loin
ben oui mais justement à un niveau
acceptable ça dit qu'il faut que j'aille
chercher ce que ça m'apporte c'est faux
que j'ai il faut je ferai pas de retirer
le bon l'aide d'un people to match
puisse se mouche aussi le danger mais
selon g pour toutes dans vie de tous les
excès sont dangereux et que ce soit en
pâtit je suis dit ah vous mieux faire de
l'excès ans parquet de l'ex en drogue
probablement
mais encore ça se trouve est une
dépendance fait attention à ce qu'ils
soient je trouve ça j'ai cru que ce soit
plus nocif doivent frapper les genoux
pour elle a résulté pour le résultat
vicky 2
j'aime emmener d'arrêter bon je fais
c'est pour ça que j'ai l'impression que
tous les excès sont nocifs tifa que oui
mais il faut trouver la balance puis
comme je dis des mots 15 mai 2001 m
clairement j'ai balancé
puis tout commençait à t'intéresser à
nutrition plus qu'un parce que je suis
quelque chose qui t'intéresse quand même
pas mal mais quand je faisais mes demi
heure on demande beaucoup
je faisais du sport sans trouble
m'intéresser à la nutrition je mange
comme une truie le médecin je
faisais attention mais je faisais ces je
faisais pas attention de façon
scientifique
puis quand je faisais mes demi heure une
même quand j'étais pressé que la 156
logique commence à faire du us
du monde ou comme on appelle ça juste la
viande le pid et du valais
je fais du paléo pendant 2 pourquoi
qu'est ce qui te plaît je voulais être
encore plus sec plus tard être plus
actuellement tout tu t'es dit eu lieu un
peu de vue que les clubs ne faisait que
tu faisais de la rétention d'eau
pèse exactement de ses puits mauger et
j'ai tendance à faire du go c'est je
regarde un bang glg le
cinéma s'est fait que je m'estimais m'en
allais pas les os effectué les paléo
pendant
je te dirai peut-être quatre cinq mois
avant la compétition tu piges écoute
juste une machine je sais ça a été mon
logement j'étais j'avais dit au bout des
dents de sucre le thé campa dans des
compétitions je sais plus je mangeais
flottement javari pour elle ça a été
fantastique monde me ronan là dessus
j'ai presque pour budget but mais j'ai
pas bu à outrance
j'ai mangé dans mon type de l'épatant en
captant six tpiy
j'ai mangé un bout d'os arrange bien
j'ai la course s'est passé ni laxiste si
j'étais mongole à
jallais vite la cgt une fusée sharif est
en pleine forme j'en aurais fait un
autre je teste octobre puis après sauter
jarret loger les enfants qui ont un
titre réalité c'est que quand tu as des
enfants
mais j'ai commencé à faire du jeu
intermittente et pourrait aussi
redescendre encore mon poids si beaucoup
lyoen mon affaire si mais si ça vraiment
bien fonctionné puis le jeûne
intermittent cité fait aussi moins
manger n'importe quelle banque passés
près cependant c'est noah s'est fait que
je suis moi je compte si je parle de la
fin j'ai fait deux anciens qui j'ai
repris du poids mais c'est parce que si
je bois puis je montre un moyen puis
sauf que je mange inévitablement moins
active man et dimanche de 12h à 8 manger
midi a eu que des mois je déjeunais
commandes mais ça fait du bien c'est
surtout les snacks de france c'est comme
ça c'est la sceller la chaussée lequel
elle s'est pointée serait que oui jma
jeunes est en phase d'arrêt de manger à
cette jeune et tu te rends pas ton sec
deutsch est pas neuf exactement
type de repas tombeur de céréales
inutile a dit si tu es petit endroit de
ses biens des affamés scarcity ça veut
dire de quoi aussi dit que je pense que
de mon côté en tout cas ce que je trouve
c'est que
je ça me permettent dans mes excès de me
contrôler après ce 10e jeu s'intéresser
à la dénutrition comme les gens passent
une série d'entraînements qui va être
course mais plus musculeux aussi tes
jeux avec l'âge de avec large tu te
rends compte que les turcs à des gens de
50 ans et plus ce qui qui qui perdent la
masse site faire la massivité quand même
qu'ils deviennent un peu remonté je
pense qu'il faut et il faut avoir un bon
cardio mais il faut avoir une masse
musculaire fait que je passe sur un
régime qui est plus protéines mais un
petit puis
fait que je mets je me réintéresse
je rencontre mon jeûne intermittent
un meilleur entraînement que de partir
s'entraîner devant ce jeu j'ai fait des
demi marathon le vendredi c'est ce
en pleine forme
j'ai rien à redire mais ce campus
c'est pas des trainings est un style
que moi que fait ch qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait ça marche jamais un homme jeu là
j'essaie d'aller quand même temps je
suis dit je vais m'entraîner agents
ouais
c'est pour ton corps brûle des grenats
le fond le dessus qui avait cherché son
état sur d'énergie dans des gros mais il
ya pas d'intensité sexuelle s'y mettront
si j'essaie d'en faire un jeu capable en
forme et si loin d'être des performances
je me suis jetée jeter je sais pas moi
je me sens bien je me sens vraiment bien
jusqu'à partie comme je dis lemay
dernière compétition j'ai fait avant ça
a été long mais ça c'est ça c'est sûr
que c'est pas optimale ben j'ai causés
mais je veux dire qu'on prend peut-être
avec sur mes sensations je suis athée si
on se fie à tous qui a jugé la sava
supposément été cherché je mange chez à
8 heures le soir puis lendemain matin je
me réveille à 7 h sur la ligne de départ
puis pouf que je finis deux heures et
demie plus tard ou deux ans à peu
importe le temps que cela rend le type
l'état rivaux afin de faire comme bon
badge elle pas de boisson
rien rien du tout je
me dis que je peux me dis que je skie
pas un repas deviennent
complet légumes un rongeur d or au
regard de parler pas avoir une
discussion un peu moi je mange la
dernière fois le yari était cet art qui
gît rien je crois qu affirment attendre
mes loyers couaillier
et 11h30 j'ai pas feinte puis je sais
que je vais aller m'entraîner avant puis
je vais sûrement me prendre un chèque à
3-4 puis peut-être un souper à 8 ça va
être à moi je suis là dessus au sujet
j'ai mangé ya 1 heure et demie puis
c'est la dernière chose effet jusqu'à un
café à l'antenne j'avais écouté amman et
est allé au podcast de bernon laval et
puis
si tu leur expliques un peu sous le
titre relation avec la bourse puis lille
tandis que tu avais si tu te fais tu es
jeune tu aimes tant qu'
x 60 et de la culpabilité des fois avec
toi parce que tu manges et où ce que tu
mangeais pas au cip ce ppi
il était un peu complètement flou le
gast et parce que je disais comme 6t
parce que autres prenant tout à fait
contraire il prône comme n'importe quoi
tu prendre équilibre dans vite cette
facture oui absolument puis jeudi ils se
hisseront nantis diète sont assis
restriction à tignes habilité ce type i
ski ski je la présente pour la grande
majorité des gens la bonne approche
aurait la culpabilité cpo
cette animation
ils sont plus vivre sans ses new skies
justement le fait qu'ils aient qui est
encore resté genre de pression le puits
tout genre de clip telle par rapport à
la bourse a dit qu'il ya plein de monde
qui développe du premier mandat ou 10 ou
mai
ces puits t elle ils vont dire
partie le pose tes jeux dans le pur
prenant 5 risque deuxièmement parle pas
du pur du monde parle pas de prime aux
anges et racé comme un débile métier
j'ai jamais mais
quand tu fais du sport gris quand cours
masse pas une affaire de standard de
bouteille à faire de son mieux être
c'est plus beau c'est plus mieux dans
société d'être plus témoins - plus m
c'est quantifiable c'est plus logique
complété à la main et efficace métier
geiser il ya bien plus que ceux là
dedans je comprends tout à fait la leur
cela comprend aussi plus je leur laisse
le temps de
manger équilibré puis c'est bien correct
après ça je pense qu'il n'y a pas une
seule approche pour une seule t pour
toutes les personnes je pense qu'on peut
modifier on peut aller jouer là dessus
on peut aller voir qu'est-ce que ça fait
aussi peser ce qui est intéressante et
je fais pas un
tcsp spawn doctrine ce dogme c'est pour
moi jeune j'aime ça j'aime ça ça marche
ça marche ici puis je fais des tests
puis je vois s'il en est cela dit je
pense que le poids c'est important parce
que le surpoids et le
décolleté de du manque de santé physique
t2 maladie n'est plus en plus de
maladies dans le monde particulièrement
aux états unis aux hockey au canada
aussi c'est je pense qu'il faut bien se
nourrir je pense qu'il faut pas trop
manger je pense que sans parler du poids
faut parler de l'importance colin la
mauvaise alimentation et la
suralimentation sur un corps puis un
moment donné c'est passé c'est pas du
body shiming personne ne se pose pas ce
qu'on me dise pas ce que je dis ce que
je dis c'est que hightrusted important
par l'icc c'est quoi si on veut une
société en santé si on trouve que notre
système de santé est surchargé surmené
aide et nous dit on
on est capable de dire aux gens d'aller
se faire vacciner mais on a de la
difficulté à dire aux gens de bien
manger de pas trop manger de surveiller
disent qu'on se construit et gère pas ce
qui est importante et je pense qu'il
faut le faire aussi cette promotion faut
la faire aussi cette promotion là c'est
important puisque c'est correct là on en
est tous différents puissent des six
collectes sauf que je trouve que ça fait
aussi partie de la réflexion qu'on doit
avoir en tant qu'entité c'est aux états
unis le son dans marde big time parce
qu'ils se nourrissent mal depuis un
moment donné tu peux pas pas tous réglés
qu'un médicament ce pauvre et c'est le
médicament va pas toucher une affaire
mais pas de repos la raison de cette
affaire le fait qu'il faut aller à base
de tout
il faut être capable d'aller à la racine
de pie pour reparler de
ce bal à dolo tic qui est que avec
bernard et
l'idée temps je comprends tout à fait
ton n'est pas pour les régimes je pense
par contre que une adaptation à faire
personnelle à chacun puis c'est dur de
le faire de façon généralistes c'est à
dire que moi je découvre dans ma vie que
ice en enlevant soit en enlevant
suscitant une rechute en surprises et en
donnant une fenêtre je me sens mieux
précieux pas dire que je mange que tu
que du pain gens mangent moins je le
vois ce que ça fait du fromage en
mangent moins c'est fait que
deux ports de produits laitiers deux
pages à ce rapport
après cela il faut avoir des conseils
généraux ce correct mais je nous est
difficile de
mettre le poing sur une un truc de
l'appliquer à tous très bas ce que tu
dis tantôt je pense que c'est ça ça se
développe le sens qu il n'y a pas une
approche fonctionne pour tout le monde
bien et qu'ils vont le qe2 le fait des
calculs et un peu plus vide d'essayer
des affaires puis un peu comme tu le
fais ça fonctionne très bien pour
d'autres puits pour certains pour
d'autres ça ça leur crée un niveau de
densité et puis ça fait quand même à
capote et ça les fait et
je pense qu'il ya moyen de rebih aussi
la science et est tellement intéressante
à ce niveau là tu es sur la nourriture
sur l'apport
et en calories sur la fed de l'affect de
différent c'est de différentes
substances moi je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup parlé beaucoup de beaucoup à
découvrir encore dit je m'intéresse à
plein d'affaires si je m'intéresse à ce
que ça peut faire sur le corps humain je
lis beaucoup là dessus mais c'est
intéressant enfin qu'à un moment donné
je pense que
je sais a évolué beaucoup le sillon n'ya
pas longtemps on a eu plein de périodes
dans vie de la période de fort chômage
de steak parce que ça bouge des artères
mais on pouvait manger du sucre mais on
peut manger alors qu était le très
convaincant finalement c'est plus le
seul problème avec ça évolue s'il faut
prendre le temps voilà c'est nouveau en
plus tu es à l'échelle à l'échelle de la
science est elle vraiment la nutrition
c'est encore une science qui somme toute
assez jeune mais exige que pour que
l'ancien parce que le
déminage alimentaire a été mise à jour
mais l'ancien duré longtemps le tic qui
a
recommandé des produits laitiers 2 2 3
grand verre de lait par jour alors que
l'on fait quand ben jeddo non
déçu
mais c'est que c'est probablement pas de
très bons ballons si c'est exact c'est
safex évolué fait que je pense que c'est
effectivement dans le monde sait dans
l'échelle la science la nourriture était
on est quand même de découvrir un peu ce
que ça donne puis il faut prendre le
temps qu'il
faudrait que sa serviette compter un peu
plus tôt des fois le team et on
le mettait surtout comme city mais dont
par exemple aux etats-unis c'est un
problème de société ce problème de santé
publique pis mais mettons la
grossophobie d'un problème de société
aussi oui mais après c'est comme un
conte jongle avec c'est
pourquoi mélanger faut juste pour
mélanger vous pouvez mélanger les
affaires faut pour faut pas penser que
c'est
que la grossophobie est acceptable parce
qu'être gros c'est nocif pour la santé
je pense que ces deux choses
complètement différentes et un surpoids
est nocif pour la santé c'est correct on
le sait maintenant faut absolument pas
penser que
parce qu'on sait ça il est
possible et de bon goût d'être méchant
envers une personne qui est en surpoids
jeunes on sait
j'ai eu du surpoids pendant un bout de
ma vie tpiy je suis pas tout le temps
mon poids santé et pis je suis conscient
de ce que ça implique puis un mois en
été je pense que c'est la conscience
sociale de l'implication de du surpoids
et de ceux des problèmes de santé et du
problème de santé publique que cause
l'obésité car en dix ans ça veut pas
dire que c'est sympathique il rajouter
on utilise ça pour rire des gens ou
parler des gens qui ont un surpoids on
dit je pense qu'il faut l'aborder en
société de faire comme ok guys ça c'est
un problème qui nous causent souvent une
surcharge et notre système de santé qui
nous pousse à développer des mets de la
médication qui patch un problème mais
qui ne règle porte ils les autres on
oublie de penser plus globalement puis à
la racine là on va survenir pour jaser
mais ces deux choses complètement
différentes
j'écoutais le podcast a fait avec avec
arnaud celui qui a mené vous parlez des
ce que lui a commencé à courir dernière
manquer vous parlez vous parlez des des
options mettons sur la route laitiers
puis lui dit je comprends pas pourquoi
je pas capable d'arrêter un pit stop
stop ya juste un tim hortons a et w j'ai
aucune solution puis pourquoi est-ce que
c'est légal c'est quoi ce que la seule
chose que tu peux faire quand et sa
route s'est arrêtée de pagne est un trio
tinbergen exemple tu peux pas arrêter
poignet un rap au poulet outil un rap au
tofu ou quelque chose qui comme chose de
quelque chose qui ouais c'est ce qui
n'est pas ultra procès ce qui est parti
tranquillement
tranquillement sa sagesse ok tu as des
options mettons sur dans un
centre d'achat dans la courte mais
encore le et moi
si j'ai un creux je vais m'arrêter un
géo mais je m'arrêterai pub
j'en prenais un café mais je m'arrêterai
pu façon je mange pas de pain même envie
tant jeune femme j'aimais beaucoup le
pain mais si j'ai à manger du pain
moment j'ai un bon croissant lors la
crée pas comme un symbole c'est vrai je
m'arrête gier je prends soin une salade
soit des trempettes soit peu importe ce
métier je m'arrête plus dans des
endroits comme ça mais tu as raison
c'est je pense que c'est devenu un truc
de sociétés de
l'ordre était de
rendre les choses efficace et le sait la
progression aussi de toute cette
société-là on ne sort-il et les familles
des cuisines puis surtout les femmes des
cuisines c'est dans une époque où
c'était cette grande inégalité là qui
marquait en les sortant on ne peut pas
appris aux hommes à cuisiner on leur a
donné des solutions de rechange qui sont
devenus du de la nourriture c'est faux
et avec le temps on est devenue efficace
on est devenus moins intéressés par la
bonne nourriture plus par la rapidité
puis un moment donné c'est ce qu'on a
infecté impétrants qui demande si ça va
revenir puis on voit apparaître d'autres
choses pour apparaître des choses plus
intéressante intelligente à manger mais
sauf que je pense que c'est une courbe
aussi de ses crampes peut pas changer ça
d'un coup c'est incroyable quand même
moi j'ai découvert
c'est moi j'ai toujours cuisine est
toute ma vie ma carte au second
d'armacham persécution et pour la femme
et deux fois par semaine c'est quand
même toujours cuisiné vraiment beaucoup
puis moi j'ai jamais mangé apport les
dîners des fois à l'école des mets
congelés
jusqu'à ce que j'en fasse moi même des
mets congelés en épicerie parce que là
je réalise qui sans manger en tabarnak
dont je pense que moi j'avais les stades
de comment ça se vendait la section
surgelés mettons dans un géo dans une
intro qui
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui
consomme soit puis moi je le sais j'en
faisais le tpiy tu regardes les
ingrédients pour dix estime h sur toutes
les world e t'attendais tu vas mourir
même si c'est bon tu sais si c'est
correct comme toile ces sept minutes
dans le chrome dans une rapide jamais ça
va te prendre sept minutes cuisiner quoi
que ce soit puis sauf que ce dimanche à
tout les soirs tu vas mourir
ça prend du temps à are et l'éducation
reid qui est tout le temps tout le temps
ces seuls mots clés puis c'est lent
c'est l'onf a reçus mais on va donner
c'est des générations c'est normal ça
mais ça faut en parler c'est important
faut pas confondre faut pas oublier ce
point l'autre c'est si important le
point de la nourriture dans le monde moi
c'est au dessus est ce que c'était
bonsoir bonsoir et avec le pam et qui
avait surgi liste est bernard laval et
je pense justement qui parlait qui avait
pas un aliment qui était pire que ça
avait circulé beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux que je me rappelle même a dit
avoir fait comme excuse c'est
factuellement vrai cette citation là
parce que oui mais ton bien ce que ça va
te faire sur ton corps je bois un bleu
il n'y a pas grand différence vraiment
sûr être correct pourtant ces
désistements de la pizza vendredi soir
c'est pas grave le lancer ce
jeu metal
énoncé comme tel prix hors contexte spaf
actuellement vrai le soliste paris en
tant qu'actif instruments j'ai la pizza
tous les repos mais
je comprends la philosophie je trouve
juste content dans une époque où on a
besoin de plus d'explications se voit
c'est juste un mais mais je comprends
tout à fait ce que derrière ce
commentaire parce que si on prend l'air
on peut même en jambes anglaises mangées
sauf que ce message de ceux qui
dans l'est dans des oreilles
peu attentive et vous ou dans des
oreilles peu peu éduqués mettons peu
outillés dangereux commandes bah oui bah
oui c'est oui c'est dangereux ici et
puis
ça nous ramène à nos habitudes de vie
puis des habitudes de vie saines je
pense que c'est essentiel t puis je
trouve qu'on des nantis on rit on parle
de plein de problèmes en même temps on a
parlé de la grossophobie litige je
trouve que ça beaucoup de sens
aujourd'hui de de mettre de l'avant les
habitudes de société qu'on avait qui
étaient de rire d'à peu près tout le
monde sans contexte et sans
compréhension et empathie hockey fait
que se tissent et je pense que c'est
essentiel qu'on parle de succès mais on
est en train de tout mélanger si ces
défauts le problème c'est qu'on mélange
on mélange la culpabilité de manger un
bang avec l'autre extrême de rien mangé
c'est toujours le milieu c'est toujours
la modération c'est toujours on n'oublie
ce fait à un moment donné des fois quand
on vote vers un extrême dans la
nourriture on va aller dans l'autre
extrême pour dire ouais mais non c'est
pas ça la solution c ne vous inquiétez
pas meilleur processus assure qu on
oublie des fois que ce processus là que
je trouve qui est essentiel puis c'est
quand tout un tir on en parle de grosse
fumée noire au dessus de mes dans le
processus d'investigation jeu qu'on leur
ait triché qu'on aurait bernard ici
picon en posant les questions qui
animent ensemble en ayant une heure et
demie prendre en compte bah oui on
pourrait essayer de mieux comprendre
cette pensée là c'est le choc est pris
en compte et que c'est surtout lui qui
se présente en tant que
country sioniste dont professionnels de
la santé finalement par des grosses
billes qui est plutôt un problème de
sociologique de sociologie qu'un
problème de santé mais que londres et
que c'est comme si
l'expertisé puis les flancs le sujet on
dirait plus envie qui m'explique je te
manquer de la santé nih qui mélangé des
affaires aussi que c'est correct c'est
parce qu'on ne mélange pas mal d
affaire.c mai mais je pense qu'il faut
et il faut les décortiquer pas être
capable d'en parler cela dit c'est avec
bernard dans ce podcast lotissement suis
un peu plat bien tes jeux
même en fait d'accord probablement avec
comme tu dis donc on verra on démarre
avec le jeu jeudi c'est j'écoute
quelques podcasts et dont celui lott c
et puis
c'est toujours une discussion
intéressante avec laquelle je suis
d'accord au fait que si c'est pour ça
que j'ai l'impression que des fois tu
sais on oblige des gens à donner son
opinion leur opinion sur un truc puis il
ressort des des liners de même qu'ils
font que son qui sont partagés je ne
sais pas ni partage bien sur facebook il
ya un clip de 30 il m'a dit forme
d'opinion sur justement une phrase qu
une personne
et non sur la personne
et des
réseaux sociaux qu'on disait au début
mais c'est tellement si j'ai
l'impression qu'ils se passer comme
une personne offert une chose publique
va avoir une information une facette le
terrain pour le pointe de l'iceberg de
quelqu'un un plus tout d'un coup tu ton
nom c'est ça c'est rapide lettre c'est
fou hein je resterai sans séance et
s'épuise comme et ça c'est une des
raisons que les qualités des réseaux
sociaux de com com du jugement permet
moi j'ai pas d'opinion à donner je ne
suis pas je pense pas que mon opinion
vaut quelque chose tellement c'est dans
ce sens ou à vous pas plus qu'une autre
témoin ce que je pense je pense pas mal
la même affaire que tout le monde dans
son soutien je pense pas mal que
l'éducation c'est la solution à tout je
pense que l'incompréhension vient d'un
manque de communication je pense qu'ils
étaient là il vient donner d'une
injustice fait qu'un moment donné
toujours rien d'otage a ajouté dans ce
bel outil puis je suis pas un expert de
pignons à toi je comprends mais est-ce
que tu lèves est aussi pour le bien des
autres
j'en suis un consommateur de pignons des
puis consommateurs j'ai discuté je vais
lire des chroniqueurs dit je vais pour
l'opinion des autres jeux je me
surprends tout le temps a amené comme à
mon dieu je
pourquoi donc cette personne n'a besoin
de partager son opinion si je toujours
surpris de tuer puisque je me dis comme
ok
qu'est ce que ça qu'est ce que ça lui
apporte à lui qu'est ce que ça lui
apporte à elle se partagera je pense
soit que je comprends tout le temps mais
politiquement ce monde et en france et
je vais pas à la juger là dessus mais
memory que je pourrais pas faire sortir
j'ai de la misère à
partager ma vie
je pense pas que ce que je fais cet
intéressant vraiment et je vois partager
le genre j'ai des moments de glisse le
cd moment où est-ce que femme je fais un
super bon c'est quelqu'un qui a fait ça
je trouve ça c'est sûr j'aime sur ça je
peux le partager pourquoi je peux même
pas dire si on arrivait coup comme ça
est fini d'après sa mémé partager le
fait que mon frigidaire marche plus que
je marche du projet la mise en jeu j'ai
pas ce réflexe il a fait ce qu'ils ont
bravo sucre et non pas fine mouche à
l'epo je constate je contacte que je
rends du vieux-mans c'est ce constat
correct
le titan bon sens a fini le veulent pas
longtemps commence juste au printemps
prochain à ce que cela soit encore john
thys d'autres projets sur la planche est
un sinon c'est ça je m'entraîne et je
finis sur les jugements avait chez
bestbuy menuiserie après ça j'ai envie
que je m'entraîne tout l'après midi ceux
ci a vu le cheval je me réinscrire au
jim
en groupe pour le sont nos piles le bain
froid mais j'ai remarqué que ma vie mon
corps réagit très bien aux chocs de
température lance m ça fait deux
semaines de suite que je vois dans un
sport aussi une journée à 50 piastres
t-il d'un bain froid et d'un sauna puis
je me rends compte que mon corps aiment
ce jeu quand je m'entraînais vraiment
beaucoup j'avais j'avais j'avais sauté
je m'entraîne depuis georges évidemment
avec lattes à la pandémie jeu je
m'envole je peux aller dans une gêne
depuis le printemps fait que je sais
quoi je pense que je vais me réveiller
je vais allez revivre ça pour voir
comment je me sens puis comment ça va me
faire sans ces faits que je fais rien
d'autre mon objectif c'est je fais que
la soirée était encore jeune fille ddt
comme fin vous vos podcasts un truc
comme ça pour ouvrir parce que c'est
grave car du coach boy whaou était fake
je compte je fais ça mais je m'entraîne
je fais comment internet afin d'assister
le fais mon test fait que je vais aller
faire pipi beaucoup de muscu fait qu'on
a eu droit les
ir juste c'est drôle parce qu'avant tout
le monde en parle c'est les aventures du
format chez huawei faites moi j'écoute
et je fais le jeu fait le bac à bac
souvent les dimanches puis hier il
testait
le froid dans le fond le typhon allait
faire des tests lui se mettait dans une
jarre des oliviers se mettant dans leur
découverte un genre de job tout en fait
le one piece qui comme qui fait que ça
te refroidi plaît prenez les signes
vitaux pour voir c'est parce que lui
dans le fond ce que si elle voit ses
excuses mettons il ya un mérite à
prendre une douche froide le matin pour
avoir lui luis attaque et surtout
l'aspect perte de poids mais ce que tu
brûles plus nrj puis la réponse est non
et sans s'écarter froid 4 mai froids il
ça change rien par contre il posait la
question tu es parce que ouais bof on en
a déjà parlé le télévie iceman le gamer
pis il pose la question parce que c'est
vrai qu'il est capable de faire ses yeux
des stats qui ont été pris sur lui ça va
produire corporels diminue pop s'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe plutôt de la
question d'octobre comme un spécialiste
de ce loto est fait comme
lui on n'est pas capable d'expliquer
tpiy 10 pour monsieur madame tout le
monde si vous aller se mettre dans des
situations comme lui vous allez coulé au
fond vous allez mourir d'hypothermie
genre de domaine dit mais lui lui on ne
sait pas pourquoi mettons tout tout seul
c'est sûr que là pour le sport mettons
les contrastes partir pour
l'inflammation c'est prouvé que ça
fonctionne et on les broie que ces
choses là mais il ya quelque chose hein
dans
la capacité du corps à s'adapter au
froid qui existent qu'on ne connaît pas
encore on n'est pas capable de tout
c'est quoi
je trouve ça vraiment que comme la
science constate qu'aucune annonce ou
genre après la foire qui sont démenties
la douche d'eau froide ça marche
possible c'est toutes ces fautes date ya
quelque chose le qu'on n'ait pas gardé
comprend pas falloir trouver c'est quoi
la recontre si ces gueux layton m à
l'ipp son corps fonctionne vraiment des
autres après si tu peux tu le
recommander aux autres mais pour
l'instant sa méthode qui vend puis comme
sa méthode c'est la chute pour ma part
j'aime pour lui et pour lui fixer vous
autres le genre mais il ya des
témoignages de gens qui suivent sa
méthode de respiration qui reçoit rester
plus longtemps dans des mêmes et olivier
justement dans les aventures de
pharmaciens garé en parlait il disait
que tu peux je suis un type de grudd en
font que tu peut amorcer davantage en
exposant au froid fait que c'est vrai
que tu es capable de devenir plus
résistants mais de façon assez marginal
au point où est-ce que c'est sur que
c'est pas ce qui explique pourquoi lui
capable de faire cela mais il était
mardi les témoignages qu'on a reçu le
philosophe lo'jo scientifiques
philosophes le témoin il fallait la
pyramide de la valeur scientifique
d'une preuve mettons pente et les
témoignages c'est juste en haut des les
rumeurs le terrain pour les plus solides
scientifiquement fait de base et des
choix de vie des choix d'habitude sur
des témoignages quand même
d'accord on a le droit à un nom exact
faut pas avoir peur de voir comment sa
fille surtout c'est après ça peut-être
que peut-être que c'est explicable
qu'est ce qu'on souhaite ce qui s'en
vient qu'est ce que
j'aimerais ça
j'aimerais ça réaliser les objectifs
d'entraînement pauvre et ce sera mon
enfant c'est con mais je sais que j'ai
troqué bain des affaires récemment sans
culpabilité en plus un mais là je veux
pas sur le pont du rock et au nom de
tous les objectifs séjour
professionnellement quitterait le
goutte-à-goutte facta pas fait tous et
pas vraiment dans l'est et quand tes
pensées pour écoute des belles
transitions différents projets mam est
pour l'instant pour l'instant le jeu
veut carrément en train de me soit
c'est la
première fois depuis que j'ai arrêté de
manger en
2017 que je faisais un programme
d'entreprendre que je ne souhaite pas un
programme d'entraînement que je lis nul
meilleur feeling c'est que c'est
extrêmement meilleurs les uns facture
j'en ai un à un les mots mon coach m'a
envoyé il m'envoyait comme mémé
entraînement de la journée puis je veux
rien rater je vais faire moins c'est mon
objectif lui tient vraiment mon objectif
le type lui répondre et puis mis mes
textes et mes entraînements de la
journée et sa victoire
c'est beaucoup de muscu je ne sais pas
tant de muscu dans ma vie c'est ça va
être ce jeu est bon c'est mon but on va
te laisses aller au jam et en traverse
le monde est venu c'était parce que
vraiment je reviens te donner -
yassa et merci merci merci bref vraiment
très cool puis bonne course merci merci
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre i entre le pitch vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
mois hors glace par mois et vous avez
les podcasts en avance xavier premier de
votre groupe d'amis avoir quitté les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tuer
le la dynamique entre les amuse tout le
temps avons une avance sur les jobs en
avance je rentre de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le
chèque le podcast su ni voulu nous
entendre jean zay davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcasts etc là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on vend jaser on va
t'il et nicole non nicoli pleut
maintenant comme un fils travaille la
place travot détail est là mais on jason
par la conversion convient d'avoir mais
ceux ci vous voulez revoir c'est ça
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétillant il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous